So if we're just concerned a part of scenario two having to do with, you know,
the check being made and
we're talking about maybe the user pulling back a pot after things have started.
We have the first step being the start,
being sent from the user interface to the hot water source.
And then the user pulls off the pot and the containment vessel senses this and
sends a message to the hot water source saying,
hold it don't pour out any more water.
And then later, the user puts the pot back on and
the contain, the containment vessel says, okay, we can now proceed.
And we can indicate that in a collaboration diagram labeling the steps one, two,
three in this case.